think of it like you go to a party
downtown in the city there's a pub
there's people spilling out of the pub
you know and it's an amazing time and
you walk up there and you're Whispering
into every person's ear and you're like
hey I throw really great parties too you
should come back to my flat uh trust me
it's amazing every time you show up with
a blog post that's what you're doing
you're like hey I throw really great
parties too and everyone's like no I
want to stay at the pub it's amazing
here right everyone wants to stay in
Twitter everyone wants to stay in
LinkedIn so you should be writing in the
environment and then sure your site is
where your best work can live but that's
not what's going to drive the result